angel before you leave can you uh uh hit  us off with that king kong line i can't  come look  i'm putting cases on all of you  can you curse on you can't curse on it  you'll be playing basketball in pelican  bay when i can shoot programmed  23-hour lockdown do you think you can do  this to me shaq you think you can do  this to me  [Laughter]  i appreciate you brother  got it before you leave can you uh uh  hit us off with that king kong line  can't come look i'm i'm putting cases on  all of you  can you curse on you can't curse on it  you'll be playing basketball in pelican  bay when i can shoot programmed  23-hour lockdown do you think you can do  this to me shaq you think you can do  this to me  [Laughter]  i appreciate you brother